sorting algorithms are used regularly in
computer science and programming
in this course you will learn how the
most popular sorting algorithms work
using diagrams and code
it's coding time with coding cleverly
but this time we're on a different
channel that's right
coding cleverly is being featured by
free code camp
this video will be about some of the
different sorting algorithms that you
can
apply to almost any programming language
the language focused in this video will
be c plus plus
however like i said you can apply the
concepts to any other languages of your
choice
like java python c and so on you would
at least need to know the fundamental
core concepts of programming especially
the basic programming constructs
like sequence selection and iteration to
understand this video
also make sure to check out my channel
coding cleverly where i've covered
almost every concept from programming
fundamentals to object-oriented
programming
all the way to data structures and
algorithms and beyond
okay so let's start by writing a simple
algorithm for sorting an array
so first of all let's include our
iostream and i encourage you to type
along with me
to get the maximum practice so hashtag
iostream
and then we have our namespace standard
and then we have our integer main
and we also have our return
zero right here so we're going to start
off with a very simple algorithm and
we're going to look at it's a
visual implementation so suppose we have
an array of four
elements and that's the four size we
have two three one and five
and b basically this is an array which
is basically
indexed having values from zero all the
way to three
so our job is to sort this in ascending
order we know that this is not in
ascending order so we're gonna use a
very simple
algorithm and i'm going to create
actually the implementation here
so then after that we go back to our
code editor and we're going to type
along
and it's just going to make much more
sense so suppose we have two variables
and we're going to have one variable
which is gonna be enlisted
on the top so we're gonna have that as i
so
that is gonna be the first one which is
zero location and then we have j which
is gonna be
the second one which is gonna be i plus
one so right after
the i is gonna be the j and we're going
to play apply actually a nested for loop
so first for loop is going to have some
condition
so after inside there's going to be a
precondition that says j is less than i
so over here what it means is that the
ray
of that j and the value of that j is
less than
the value of that i now that's what i
meant by
array sub j and less than array sub so
the value of j
less than the i value this is our
condition that's going to be inside of
our nested for loop the internal one
and this is the condition if it's true
we're going to create a temporary
variable
and we're going to store the value of i
so whatever's in i so in this case
2 is in it so 2 is going to be stored in
temp so then we're going to swap it
using a we're famous topic methodology
is equal to j and j is equal to
temp variable so whatever the temp value
was it actually was i's value i's value
was 2 so that's going to be in j
so actually we just implemented a swap
methodology here
so right after that we're gonna check in
this condition so in this case we have
two and three so value of three
is actually greater than the value of
two so in this case
the condition won't be true and it won't
execute so this is just gonna skip the
value
and we're just going to make our j now
increment to the next portion
so we're going to skip this so i just
cross this out and now i go
and put this next pointer over here in j
so now i
and j now you can see that j's value is
less now we have one and we have
comparing with two so
g one is less than two so this condition
is now true
you could see that one and two are going
to be located
um talking about the values and now
that the condition is going to be
satisfying here so
we're going to look over here that temp
is equal to i
and then we have the value which is i
so what is i2 so that's going to be in
that temp variable
i is equal to j now j is actually one so
i
is equal to one so we're going to have
here i is equal to
the value one now after this we have j
so j is equal to now the value of temp
now temp value was
actually two so now you can see that
this swapped value so we have
i which is now one except for two now
two and now over here in the j position
instead of one
now we either have the value of two now
you can see that swapped out and now
j's value going to be incremented so you
can see that the index is now
no longer going to be here and now it's
going to be in the fifth eleme
actually the last one which is the where
the fifth value is
and we're going to be checking again
we're going to say i and j we'll say j
is less than i well
no it's not j is greater than i so now
this portion of that nested for loop
will be terminated
and what what's going to happen now is
that i is going to all going to be
incremented so i plus plus
and we're going to have i now plus one
so
originally where j was right so now
there that's where i is going to be
and ah actually what we see here is that
j is always going to be i plus one like
what we mentioned before this is our
sorting
algorithm process that we need so it's
just going to be side by side
and they're going to be adjacent to each
other initially and then after that
they're just going to be incrementing so
like just like j's position so we have j
over here and we have i and j so if i
look over here
we have i which is three and j which is
two
can check the condition that now that's
true again so what's going to happen
is that j is less than i that is true
and we're going to process this temp is
temp is equal to
now you could guess what's happening
here now temp is equal to the value of i
which is three now
so three is going to be placed here so
there you go three
and then after that we have i is equal
to
now the value of j j is actually two so
we're just gonna have two over here
i is equal to 2. and then the last one
which is j
is equal to the value of temp temp was 3
so that place is over here so now we
just basically swapped it again
so we have instead of 3 we have 2 over
here and instead of 2 we have
3 over here so you could see now that j
is now going to be incremented again to
the last one and we can see i
is just in the same exact position and
it's going to compare two and five
well that condition is not satisfied for
this uh condition so it's just gonna
increment that process again i and j now
it's going to compare and say 3 and 5
well that
condition is also not true for that
while loop to be executed
so now we have this i and j in red
so you see that there's nothing to be
changed
so we have uh actually our our algorithm
is working
and we see that one two three and five
you can see one two
three and five there are in ascending
order
and that's how our algorithm was
supposed to work
so this visual implementation of this
algorithm
helped us and now we could map this into
our code
so we're going to be right now typing so
i would encourage you to type along
with me so let's just get things started
okay so the thing here is that we're
going to have to create an array
and i call it an array and i suppose we
want to have a size
so i could define something over here on
the top so i say hash define
and i say max and i say that's the
hundred
all right so this is the maximum value
so we just put max here
and what i could say here is that i
could ask the user
to enter a number
n and that will be the size and it
should be
in between 0 to 100 so
it's going to be input and then it's
going to be n now i need to
define an n here so i'm just going to
say integer and
so this is the integer n now inputting
values in an array
so inputting up values in an array we're
gonna do four and we say int
i is equal to zero i is less than n
and we say i plus plus really simple and
then we have
the rand function that's going to put
values randomly inside of the
each indices so we could say array sub
i and we could say just the rand
function
and that's it so this is going to give a
number between 0 to
the rand max whatever the integer max is
so what we could put here is that we
just have to include one more header
file
for the rand function so it's called c
standard
library and there you go so c
standard library is done now we have
values inside of this
let's output our array so outputting
the unsorted array
so unsorted array we could just
basically say 4
int i is equal to 0
i is less than n and then we have i
plus plus and then we say console output
array sub sub i and we put this space
and hopefully we'll get an array just
put an end line right here at the end
and now i save my code so i'm going to
run it using my g plus plus compiler so
over here i'm going to be writing
g plus plus my name which is um
part one and we have cpb and
hopefully it's going to be compiled now
we could just say a to run it
enter a number n so basically i could
say
10. now it's going to give me 10 random
numbers for my
a array so it has 41
this this and this and all the way to
10. so you can see that these are 10.
let's run this one more time
and now i'm gonna input 20. now it's
supposed to give me 20
random integers so now there you go how
about
having 50 now 50 random integers now you
got my point
over here it's creating a randomized
array and it's putting some random
values but you could see over here
that these are not sorted in any kind of
order they're not in
ascending nodes they are in descending
and now that's our job to put that
so we could say 41 and you can see that
this is a number that's greater
but then after that you could see a
smaller number and what is this even
meaning
so we need a properly managed array so
let's create a properly managed array so
what we could do here
is right after this let's create a
sorting algorithm so
sorting an array so how we're going to
sort this array
first of all let's go and open a for
loop so we could say 4
into i is equal to 0 i is less than n
and then we say
i plus plus and then right after this we
can put an
another input array so we could say this
another loop that's going to be
nested inside of the beginning one so
it's going to be j
but this is careful this is the next
value after the array
and i'll tell you what's the reason
behind this say j less than n
and we say j plus plus and now inside of
this
is basically our concept that's going to
be applying with
array sub j is less than array
sub i now what does this mean i'll tell
you all of this
so suppose we have an array and this
says that if array sub j is less than
array sub because
look at this so this is an array and you
will see that it's in order
so you can see that this is this i value
which is starting from zero and this is
the j which is
starting which is greater than i one one
times
so you'd say that j is this and this is
i now
if i had a randomized array so let's say
i had
five over here so you could see that
this is not in ascending it's
basically 10 and then it's 5. why is 5
over here
something bigger should be appearing so
the condition here is that a race
sub j is less than array sub i so
meaning
if array sub j which is this is
less than array sub i and that is the
case now what we want to do we want to
swap the values
so what we could do by swapping the
values so
5 could be over here and the original
value 10
should be placed over here how do we do
this because
5 10 30 and 40 will be then sorted and
the thing is that we're gonna have to
create an input uh integer temporary
something
so we're gonna put that and assign that
with i now once we have that assigned
with
i now what we could do here is that we
could change
array sub i and we could say to that to
array sub j so we're assigning a raise
of i's value with array sub j's value
and now we can have array sub j's value
and we could put that
as temp value so this is going to
improvise our array in a sorted fashion
and it's going to be in
ascending order a s c e n d i n g
o r d e r so this is going to be an
ascending order
so it's going to check and then after
that it's going to do this
it's going to go into our next iteration
which is going to be i is equal to 1
so plus plus increments to this so it's
going to be this value
and then it's going to be checking with
this value and it's going to see
if it's in the case that it's not right
it's going to swap it
or else it's just going to next do this
next iteration
until the array is done
examining so once it's done you could
just break out the loop
and once your break like you're free so
what's
once you're free you return to zero so
this is going to give me
my array in ascending order but now we
don't have anything
displaying it so let's display this
array so
i'm just going to write comments sorting
the array now we're going to display
[Applause]
the so let's just say the sorted
array so displaying the sorted array we
just
do a basic for loop i is equal to zero
we could say i less than n and then we
say i plus plus
and then over here which we could add
is basically console output and we say
array sub
i and then we say this
and now let's just put an end line right
here
now let's run the code so basically go
back to our g
plus plus compiler and we're gonna be
running our code but first of all let's
compile it and i'm just going to give a
hyphen o flag to indicate that this is a
new
um executable and i'm just going to call
it run so i'm going to hit the
compiling button compilation is
successful
now i'm just going to run so now you can
see enter a number
n so enter a number n meaning that
let's just enter some random number and
it's going to
create an array with some randomized
values uh
in each indices so let's have 20. now
these are 20 random numbers
you can see over here for 2041 and all
of this which is
unsorted it's just in random order and
then after that it sorts it
and you can see my sorting algorithm
does the trick and
sorts them in ascending order that's
pretty
amazing okay now let's do one other
thing
for us to have a descending order
fashion uh one other thing i want to do
here is that uh i want to tell that this
is going to be the sorted so i could
just write a console output and i'd say
sorted so sorted and
right here displaying the sorted array
and the other thing that i want to do is
i just want to
show you how descending works so this
less than sign which is array sub j
less than a race of i will just be
turned into a race of j
greater than array sub i so if it's
greater
then swap it so that's basically
descending order so i'm just going to
change this ascending
to d e s c e
n d i n g so this is now gonna be in
descending order
so it's gonna run again so i'm just
gonna compile this basically
um and then we're gonna run it
and now let's have a value like 22 now
you have these values which are 41
and all of this in random order
and then after that you call the sorted
basically
prompted out on the terminal screen and
then after that you sort them in
descending order fashion and look how
awesome that took
so that's it with this one and now let's
continue with the other
sorting algorithms so the next sorting
algorithm is called the selection sort
one of the most
common and most famous well-known
sorting algorithms in the world
so how we're going to implement this is
basically first type along
and we're going to be explaining side by
side as well as going to give a brief
explanation at the end so um just keep
on typing
along with me so hash include we're
gonna have input output stream
and then we're gonna have using
namespace
standard and then we also have integer
main
and we also have the return zero
now what we're going to do here is
basically versus we're going to create a
swap function
so what i'm going to be implementing is
basically a swap function
so void and then we have swap and then
we have
basically an array we're going to have
and it's going to be swapping so
i'm going to show you that it's going to
have an x value and it's going to have a
y value
so it's going to be implementing that
famous swap function
process uh that we've been doing so
what's going to be
doing is basically integer temp is going
to be having a sub
x as the first value so a sub
x so a sub x is going to be equal to a
sub y and then what i have is a sub y
equals to the temp variable so and
that's
how we swap something so suppose we have
an array
inside of it and we just call it an
array and we're going to have some
values to it so let's say
some random values and what we want to
do is basically we want to swap the
process over here if we have some random
values um they're not matching and we
want to swap them we could use a swap
function like just we did in the basic
algorithm in the beginning what we did
ascending order so basically we're
implementing selection sort so we
created our first function which is swap
the second function that we're going to
be doing is basically the selection
sword so how this is going to go is
basically we're going to have a void
and we're gonna call this as a selection
sort and it's gonna have
two input parameters first one is gonna
be the array and the second one
is basically gonna be the size of the
array now inside of this is gonna
have the location index which is zero
it's gonna always start from zero array
start from zero
just that and now after that it's going
to loop through this so it's gonna be i
less than n minus one we're gonna loop
to the last s
the last element so n minus one is the
last element and then we're gonna have
to find
the the value that should be smaller
than the value that we're
specifying as i zero and it should be
like
swapping the function so we're gonna
have to indicate one j over here
so it's gonna be called and we're going
to use another function which is going
to be called location of smallest
and don't worry i'm going to be teaching
what this is
so basically we're going to have a sub i
and we're going to have
n minus 1. so we're just going to have
three input parameters here we're going
to have the array passed in
and you know this is passed by reference
so it's always going to be the same
array no matter where you're going
and then we have i which is going to be
the current location it's always going
to be incrementing
and it's going to be 0 over here it's
going to be changing and over here is
the ending point
so that's the last one ending last
element so swap is gonna be um
implemented here and it's gonna have
three input parameters just like we did
before so it's gonna have the array
which is small a and then it's gonna
have the size of the i
and it's gonna have this j so basically
i which is going to be
the uh index so it's going to be the
first element and the second element and
wants to swap them
so it's going to be implementing this
swap function and it's going to be
incrementing i plus plus here
so this is how it's going to be doing
now we need here
is the location of smallest function so
let's just make it
right here so what we're going to do
here in the location of smallest
is basically have a return type of int
because it's going to be returning
a value of j so you can see that j is
integer so it needs
a return type of int so over here
location of smallest
let's have some input parameters the
first input parameter is the array
and the second parameter is the s and
this third input parameter is the ending
point
and you might be asking why i did this
and you can see over here that
the starting point is going to be i the
ending point is going to be n minus 1
so it's always going to be checking at
the end so it's going to be looping
through this whole array
and trying to find the smallest and once
it finds the smallest
from i and then it's going to swap the
value using the swap function and that's
how we're going to be
implementing this selection sort
algorithm so
if i'm going to create an i over here
i'm just going to create intermediary
intermediary variables and one is going
to be i is equal to s
so i s so i is going to be as the
starting point
and then we're going to have j which is
going to equal to
um basically i not s so we're going to
implement it
and we're going to say whatever i is
that's going to be when j
and i over here is the starting point
and then what we'll do here is that
basically we're going to have our loop
again
so while we're going to have i less than
equal to
e which is the ending point now if
a and then we have a sub
i which is the first element
if that is less than a sub j if we find
some kind of thing that is greater so a
sub j is greater
so what we would say is j is equal to i
just want to swap right we want to
locate it
and then after that what we want to do
is basically
increment it using i plus one
right so that's going to be incremented
and then we're going to return the value
of j
and don't worry i'm going to be
explaining this through a graphical
representation
so you know this is how it's done so we
have our three functions we have a swap
function
and we have a location of smallest
function and we also have a selection
sort function
let's create a display function to
display the contents of the array so
it's going to be called display
it's going to have an integer array and
it's going to have a size of the array
which is
n and what you're going to do here is
basically it's going to start from
0 and what how it's going to be
implementing
is basically while the i is less than
n and then we're going to be displaying
the contents of the array by using a
sub i and we're going to have the double
quotes over here which is space and just
going to
it's going to keep on listing them out
and then it's going to print an end line
over here just to make the format a
little more prettier
so right after that what we'll do is
basically
have the array over here specified let's
just create an array
which is going to be called arr and it's
going to have some random values so it's
going to have 102
12 i'm just giving random values over
here it's just in
random format it needs to be sorted
using my selection sort
function so i'm just going to pass this
in so you can see that this is random
and now what i'm going to do is
basically calculate the size how to
calculate the size
one of the process i'm going to use is
basically the size of operator
size of operator is going to pass in and
it's going to have the array
and then it's going to have the size of
basically the integer variable so
basically
you can see that this is the data type
and it's going to be four
the array is basically the whole thing
so you'll see one
two three four five six
seven and eight and nine nine multiplied
by four
which is basically 36 and now 36
will be basically divided by the integer
which is going to be four so 36 divided
by four
is going to give you the value which is
nine so nine is going to be the answer
right here
so once this is the size um i'll just
comment over here and say
size equal to nine what we want to do
here is basically we want to
implement our selection sort but first
of all let's just display it so let's
just display
and we're just going to pass in the
variable and the size
so it's just going to automatically
display because it's a void function and
its purpose is to display it
and then right after that let's just
call our selection sort l function
and it's going to ask for a array and
also a size
and then after that we'll just display
our selection uh sorted array using
array and then we have size
so once i do this i'll just execute and
run it so basically let me go in my
terminal screen over here i'm going to
write g
plus plus i'm going to use the selection
sort dot cpp
and or we know that by default it's
going to be a so
i'm just going to run it and i'm going
to say oh and i'm going to say selection
sort so now it's compiled and now let's
run it so selection sort
now you can see over here we have some
random stuff what's going on
okay so something went wrong
ctrl t to break the code something went
wrong in this code and let's just check
what it's wrong what's wrong in this so
we have i
less than n and we have it's
incrementing so this is processes okay
n minus one is okay there's some
infinite loop that's been
created using selection sort array and
then size
and so let's just look over here okay so
i forgot to increment this i
plus plus so just right here i had to
increment and now it's going to be
working so
basically we're done that and let's just
run this code once again
selection sort and now let's call this
and look at that
we had this array which was unsorted
which is 102 12
193 19 whatever 32 and now
what we did is pass in the selection
sort and it sorted the array for us
in 11 12 39 on an ascending order now
ascending order is that
like if you have the same value it could
be equal or it has to be greater
so just in case if i have a value like
11 and
11 they're going to be in the same
adjacent locations and then after that
it could be a bigger value
so that's sorted in selection sword i
really hope you
enjoyed and you understood so what i
want to do
is one other thing is basically show you
how the implementation is done
so suppose that the array is sorted like
this in the memory
so we have some kind of indices
so we have like five and we have four
and we have three we have seven and we
have nine
so we want to sort this in ascending
order so what we could do it by default
with selection
sort it does is that it sort makes this
i as the index of zero
and it will check for j so what it my
process here is like
that location of smallest will be called
and you can see in my code which
is basically in here so i'm just going
to show you over here
what i see here is that um the location
of
i 0 and then while i is not less than n
minus one the last element
what we do is we get the j and we put
now in the location of smallest passing
a we have the i variable which is
basically going to be zero
and n minus one which is the last
element and it's going to be the
location of smaller so location of
smallest is going to locate
for the variable which is uh going to be
this smallest one
uh even i less than equal to e if it's
less than or equal to
so if it finds it it's going to sort
that as j and it's going to return that
value so you could see
what's happening is that it finds the
smallest so you see that the smallest
here is three
so j is going to be pointing here and
then it's going to be applying that
sorting algorithm which is going to cut
swap this so you can see over here that
it's going to be swapping so we have
3 over here and then initially 5 is
going to be over here but what we want
to see here is that in this
text editor is that this is basically
displaying so we have the selection sort
and then once we go back into our um
selection sort algorithm we have a swap
function swap is going to get this value
of i and the j that's returned from here
and it's going to swap it so basically
the simple swap algorithm it's going to
swap the both
values and then after that it's going to
increment and it's going to go to our
next location so you could see in the
place over here it's going to now not
it's not going to be pointing over here
now anymore and it's going to be
pointing over here
and now this j is not going to be over
here so just want to indicate that
this j will now gonna be pointing
somewhere else so we have this i
now incremented over here so i is gonna
be incremented over here
now this is gonna be its base and what
we're gonna be
checking now because this is now gonna
be sorted with three so now we're always
uh basically over here so now we're
going to look for a value that is going
to be smaller than
4. so basically is there something
smaller than 4. it's not so that we just
increment
and we say i is going to be over here
now it's 5. if there's something
following it's okay so it's going to be
checking all and it's going to go
throughout the loop
until the whole array is sorted so i
hope you understood this concept of
selection sort through this graphical
implementation
now we're going to go to our next
sorting algorithm and let's go
towards it all right so now let's look
at another sorting algorithm this is
called the bubble sort algorithm and
it's going to go as follows so basically
you have to include your input output
stream
and you're going to have to do your
namespace standard
and let's just go simply
write our boilerplate code
okay so boiler uh this is bubble sort is
gonna also deal with
swapping so we're gonna have to include
this swapping methodology which is
basically swap and then we have an
integer array
we have an x value we have a y value
and basically when we go over here we
have
actually a temporary which is going to
be assigned to
the first value and then we have the
first value which is a sub
x is going to be assigned to the a sub y
value and then the a sub y
value will be equaling to the temp value
so this is how the swap works
and now let's have a bubble process so
the bubble process is a little bit
different
how it's different is that from
selection sort that we
already covered um we actually went from
the top
right so we went from the top and then
we went our way to the bottom
so in bubble sort we're going to go in
the bottom to the top so
i'll just explain it so first just type
along so
it's going to be bubbly bubble and then
what what this process is going to do is
it's going to do some specific process
it's going to get an array and it's also
going to get the size of the array
and we're going to go back to this a
little later so let me just i just wrote
the signature right now
and i'm going to go and talk about the
void bubble process
so the bubble sort actual functions this
is the actual bubble sort function and
what we're going to do is basically it's
going to have that same integer array
which is
right here and then we have the size and
n
so now over here what we want to do is
basically start
from the portion what i was saying that
the
bubble sort is going to be adopting so
the bubble sort is going to say integer
i
integer i is equal to 0 and what we need
is while
we have i is less than n
minus one the last element
we could have bubble process so bb bble
bubble and it's going to have the array
and the end value
which is n is going to be the size is
going to be the array and it's going to
increment its away
so it's just going to go and increment
so in the bubble
what we're going to have is in here now
we're going to open it
and we want to start so the bubble
process is going to be
from the i so it's going to start from
the last element
so that's what i was talking about n
minus 1 is the last element
and it's going to go like while and we
have basically i
greater than zero so i greater than zero
and now inside of this is if we have
a condition that if a sub i
now a sub i should be less than a sub i
minus one
now this means that there's an a sub i
if it's the top portion is greater
so what you want to do is that if a sub
i
is less than the a sub i minus 1
what you want to do is swap it so we're
going to swap it using this swap
function that we already have
it's going to take a it's going to take
the i element
and it's going to take i minus 1. so
that's how it's going to swap it
and we're going to have it generically
having going minus minus
because we're starting from n minus 1
it's going to go all the way
to 0 so this process
should work so now after that we should
have our display function
and we're ready to go so basically
display over here
have an array and we also have the size
of the array
which is some kind of size i would just
call call it as that
and then inside of it we need a an input
so i would just say
some kind of i is equal to 0 integer and
then we have the loop process which is
going to start from i
less than n and then soon as go so
basically
i is less than n and you want to process
it so array
and then we have the ice value and we're
just going to keep on
going like that until we reach our
ending point so we just console output
over here
yeah and just to make it a little more
similar to the previous one i'll just
change this to just n
because this one's matching here so now
let's create an array over here
and i'm just going to call it as integer
array and i'm just going to give some
random elements to it
so let's just say this and then this and
then
something like that this this
and 33 okay this is just random stuff
now i want to sort this so i'm just
going to first display it so i'm going
to display
i'm going to say array and also need my
size
data type so actually my size variable
so i'm going to have size and over here
i'm going to say
size of and i'm going to have the array
and i'm going to say size of
and i'm going to have the int it's going
to give me the size now what i could do
here is basically have the display
function called and then the sorted
function so it's called bubble sort
so i'm just going to name it bubble sort
i'm going to pass in my array i'm going
to pass in my size
i'm going to display once again so i'm
going to display array and then i'm
going to pass in the size
now it's supposed to work so let's just
go to our
g plus plus compiler over here let's
just type
bubble sort bbl sort and we say dot cpp
and let's just name it something like
hypno bbl
so rt and there you go right uh compiled
and there you go iran whoa what happened
over here
i think we did the same exact mistake so
let's just go back over here
and see where we went wrong okay so we
just forgot to increment on while loops
to remember to do this this is really
important
okay so i plus plus over here so that it
just
loops out and it doesn't cause an
infinite loop so
over here and let's just go back over
here to compile it
recompiling it and running it again you
can see that my
original array was 102 and then 293 and
then 1939
and all of that and then once we passed
in our bubble sword
it actually sorted out some from 11 38
102
and all the way to the last element so
that was pretty cool assorting an array
um in ascending order using bubble sword
collection sort
because the uh the methodology was
basically a little bit different so
i just want to show you how this is
implemented in a graphical way so
so the implementation of the bubble
process is basically similar to what we
did with selection sort but in actually
reverse order
we have the swap function that's going
on but we have this
visualization that could help us
understand how this process is working
so suppose we have some random values
here we have three we have five
we have one we have four and we have
let's say
three now the bubble process is going to
work like this so let me just
go over here and now let's see so it's
going to start from the bottom and it's
going to compare these two values
now it says that three and four now what
you mean that
is basically bubbling meaning it's
liquid portion is on the bottom and
liquid portion is
basically heavier than the bubble bubble
is lighter bubble makes it
flow on the top so when you compare a
liquid and a bubble bubble is lighter so
bubbles should be on the top
so this is exactly the same thing
they're talking about the weights so
four weight
is heavier than three weight so four
should be on the bottom and three should
be on the top so this is
one actual process what's happening here
is that the swap function will be called
and this is going to be changed to three
and this is going to be changed to four
and then after that bubble will go up
over here one step level so it's gonna
go from here now it's gonna go over here
so now it's gonna compare three and one
so three and one
actually what's different now so you
have over here is basically
um you say one and three so actually
it's okay so three is heavier than one
so one it's okay so go again uh over
here one and five
so five is heavier so basically five
will go on the bottom
and one will go on the top now now over
here now
one and three so basically three is
heavier so three will go on the bottom
right here so just three is on the
bottom right here and then one it will
be on the top
so this is one actual bubble process and
you see one three five
three and four right now we basically
did our one process here and we sorted
till this portion um there is more
processes
and you'll need to do one more bubble
process so again you're gonna have to go
from the bottom
so you're gonna check um like this so
basically we're gonna start again
and we're gonna see the values once more
so
forgive my writing so four and then we
have
three and we have five then we have
three again over here and we have one so
now four and three
which is heavier it's okay go up here
compare these two values
now three and five so three and five
actually five is heavier so five will go
on the bottom
so five is over here just cross this one
out and this
portion will be having three now now
three and three well actually it's the
same equal so it's going to be okay so
one in okay so it's okay so one three
three five
four now one more process so after one
more process so we're gonna have
uh one more process so let me just erase
all of this now we're gonna have even
one more process and
now this should be our final bubble
process so let's just look at the values
again
over here and then over here and then
over here and then over here so
this is one and then this is three and
now this is three as well
and now this is five and this is four so
it's going to start from the bottom
and you see that five and four well five
and four this
is different this is heavier so the
heavier portion should be on the bottom
and the lighter portion should be on the
top so four is going to be over here
and then 5 should be over here so 5 4
and then 3 3 1 1 it's okay so this is
our exact sorted array and this is how
we're going to be sorting
our array in bubble sort a slower and it
depends on the number of
inputs so it could vary and
exponentially grow
as the inputs increase so that was
bubble process
all right so now let's jump into
insertion sort so this is pretty much
different from the other two that we've
included right now which
one was selection sort and the other was
bubble sword so
i would just encourage to type along
with me and the explanation will be
doing
side by side so let's just go and
include this main
and then let's just go over here and
return the zero okay
okay now what's gonna happen here is
that we're not going to have a swap
function like we did with the other ones
what we're going to have is basically
some differences now the difference is
that we're going to have this
insertion sort function and the
insertion sort is going to basically
have an array
it's going to have one more thing that
is gonna be inside of it so the first
thing that's gonna have is gonna be the
size
this is pretty much the similar and one
thing here is that it's gonna start from
one
not from zero like others that do
because we're assuming something and
assuming is
that where the assumption is basically
that some portion of the array is
already sorted beforehand
and we just have to like insert elements
be into that sorted array and that's how
our process is gonna be done
so we're gonna go and we're gonna have a
while loop so that i could
uh tell you that it's going to go in a
while loop it's going to go to
n and it's going to say insert insert
now this is going to be the function
that's going to be called and this
function is going to take in an array
it's going to take in the size it's
going to take in the element
which is going to be the portion that
i'm going to be talking about and then
this is going to keep on incrementing i
plus plus
right like in other languages like i is
equal to
i plus 1 whatever it is
ah man i can't get the plus right okay
so just like that
so i plus plus whatever it is like that
so now let's have
so the insert element how do we do this
insert i think
so let's go over here and after this
let's just talk about the insert i
so this is actually something that's
also void
and it's going to have the insert height
element so just height over here
and now inside of it we're going to have
the array we're going to have
basically we're going to have the
integer n size we're going to have the
integer
i size which is specified over here
we're going to have this key variable
a mid intermediary variable that's going
to store our i
location or basically the value of our i
and now it's going to say
int j and this is j is going to be the
last element of that sorted array so the
last element of that sorted way is going
to be i minus one because i
is actually after the sorted ray and i
minus one will be the one
the last element so we're gonna have a
loop again and we're gonna have two
conditions for this case
we have j is greater than equal to we
have j is greater than equal to zero
and we also have one more condition that
j
should be actually greater than the key
so if j is greater than the key we're
just going to keep on looping this
so not a g j or whatever it is a key
so a sub j so let me just have this a
and then a j over here not just plain j
okay
so a sub j should be greater and then
the j should be greater than equal to so
what's going to happen here is that
a sub j plus one this is gonna be
implementing and it's gonna equal to j
and i hold on i'm just gonna teach you
this
uh don't worry so now we're gonna have j
is equal to j
minus one now it's just gonna keep on
decrementing going to the top like a
bubble sort it's gonna go
up and up and up until you reach that
less than equal to zero or
if a sub j is basically greater or if
it's less than
something like if it's less than uh then
it's gonna just break out
less than the key and naturally what's
gonna happen here
is if this condition is false we're
gonna have a sub j
plus one where we're trying to implement
and we're gonna put that key thing
inside of it that
lost value and now just have this
display function which is going to be
over here let's just have it over here
so void let's have a display
and let's have an integer array and then
let's have a
the size of it and then let's have
something which is going to be the
i it's gonna start from zero it's gonna
go basically from while
and it's gonna just check that i is less
than n
and then it's gonna go and say our
console output is gonna say a
r r actually it's not a r it's going to
be a sub i
and it's going to be i and then it's
going to be that over here there's
going to be a comma right there and then
there's going to be an
n line semicolon
right here and actually not this
i don't want that i just want a
semicolon um and this is going to be
incrementing so
i plus plus and then we're going to have
a
n line over here there you go and let's
just get some
data from our previous sorting algorithm
so like a bubble sort let's just get
uh some of the data just the array
portion not anything else so just
get this portion over here let's just
copy this and just come here and just
paste it
so i'm just going to go here and we're
just going to paste it right here so
the only thing i'm going to be changing
here everything is okay i just want to
sort it using my function so i'm just
going to call it with my insertion sort
uh actually yeah so insertion sort is
going to be called
okay so the insertion short should be
over here let's see
yeah the insertion sword is right here
it's going to go and it's going to call
this one
insert i it's going to uh it's going to
perform some operation and then it's
going to go back
plus plus it's going to keep on doing
and it's going to keep on calling this
insert
so many times until um the thing is
sorted and then after that we just
display it so let's just run this code
i'm going to go over here my q plus plus
and let's just clear this
screen and let's just compile so
basically g plus plus
ins sort insertion sort dot cpp
and then we can say uh hyphen o flag and
then say ins
sort okay it should be working compiling
okay so there's a warning over here and
25 no return statement invert function
returning non-void
25 let's see 25 where are you 25 is over
here and there is
should be something over here in search
and sort it doesn't have a return type
wow
should we have a void so let's just have
a void over here let's just go back here
and now let's just compile recompile it
and there you go now we have ins sword
so insertion sort
and if i run this you're going to have
this sorted so 102
293 1939 1832 yoyoyo
11 38 102 293 311
and this is also sorted in ascending
order now let's have the
implementation so this is basically an
array just a random
sample and we have 379 and somehow this
is basically sorted
from here how'd that happen just
randomly it just sorted beforehand
and now our eye is going to be over here
so it's going to be after that sorted
and then the js can naturally be going
to be over here but remember i said that
it's going to be i minus 1. so this is j
and the first process is going to happen
so if i go over here back in my code um
so my code is over here
and if i see over here that this is
going to be the process insert
it has an array it has the inside it has
the element i and it says that key is
equal to a sub i
so there's going to be a variable that's
going to be sorted and j is equal to i
minus one and
it's going to say that j is greater than
equal to zero and a sub j is greater
than the key
so it should be working like that and
let's see if i could implement here
here so we have a key variable so let's
just have a key over here so key
k e y store that value inside of it
which is going to be uh something inside
so what's it going to be it's going to
be the value of i it's going to be a sub
i so that's 4.
so 4 is here now ignore that now what
you're going to do is basically
you're going to check the condition and
the condition is true why because a sub
j is not it's not it's a greater than
equal to zero
actually uh if i if i go back over here
where am i okay so you could see that
it's
j is greater than equal to zero it's
perfect
and then a sub j is greater than key now
if i talk about the a sub j
now if i talk about that let me just see
a sub j
is basically this nine right now and we
have a key which is four so
that a sub j is greater so no no offense
we're we're still working
okay so the work the thing is gonna
still work um if i go back over here
we're gonna have a sub j plus one is
equal to a sub j
so that means that we're gonna have
something that we're going to be
implementing so a sub j
is going to be over here so we're going
to go over here
so this is going to mean that j plus 1
is this portion and it's going to equal
it
it's going to sign this 9 over here and
what's going to happen is that it's
going to go minus 1. so j is not going
to be here anymore now it's going to go
over here
okay so that was now that's one process
of that loop
so that's one process of it let's go
again so a sub j
greater than this is greater j is
greater than equal to 0 and a sub j is
greater than the key because
the key is four and j is seven so that's
perfect now let's go back over here
and we see that a sub j plus one is
equal to a sub j
and we have j minus one a process again
so whatever that value was
so we have seven over here that seven is
going to be now over here okay so the j
is going to go up here now
and it's going to remove it you can see
that the is still over here in this
location and you can see that the 4
was removed so we don't have that that
value anymore that
it just changed to 9. see over here this
is 9. and where does this nine come from
it came from here so with a seven came
from it came from here
so this is happening so we have this
lost value over here stored in our key
so that was the purpose of the key wow
nice key so now we're gonna do is
basically go over here
and we're gonna see a sub j plus one and
it's gonna it's gonna see this condition
is a j greater than equal to zero well
that's true if i
look at that position over here it's
over here it's greater than or equal to
zero but it is equal to zero so it's
true
but the second condition is not true why
a sub j is greater than key
and actually it's not greater how is it
not greater
it's less than because it's three now
this key is greater so this just
terminates that loop
and what's going to happen now is that
the key is going to be sorted inside
of this um this portion over here which
is j plus one
so that key value which is four is going
to be over here now this four is going
to be over here three
four and seven nine whoa this is sorted
and now it's gonna
it's gonna move on and this is i now new
position of i
and this is going to be a new process so
that's how it's going to be starting if
i look back over here
so you can see a sub j plus 1 is equal
to key and then the process starts again
if you want to do it and that's how
basically we're going to sort it insert
sort it's gonna
increment its eye value again it's gonna
go in the new playstation and then after
that position and then after that we
have insert
and then the process starts again and
again and again until
the whole damn array is sorted and then
we get this ascending order of it so i
hope you understood this concept of
insertion sword
really if you took this concept and
overall like
take a practice of it i i definitely
know that you can do it so next
off we're gonna be diving into another
algorithm let's dive into the merge sort
algorithm so let's just type along
iostream
namespace standard
main
and the return zero semicolon okay so
let's create some functions here
and let's just explain it the way we do
it so
first of all let's just find our way for
the merge sort
so we're going to initially have a merge
sort
function so how this is going to work is
basically we're going to say
void m-r-g-s-o-r-t
and we're going to say we're going to
have an array inside of it
and we're going to have the size of that
all right
so this is going to have another
function inside of it it's going to call
another function and
what this process is called is called
actually
this is called a wrapper function and
it's going to pass into an
auxiliary function so this is a wrapper
function
all right so what we could say is um
this is merge sort and it's going to
have the array inside of it it's going
to have the size of that array
and it's also going to have one other
additional parameter so
uh additional thing is that it's going
to have the size but before that
it's going to have one other thing it
should have the index of the first
element
so it's going to be the array the index
of the first element and then the size
of that basically size minus one
and this is how the merge sort is going
to be over here we're going to have that
auxiliary function called so on the top
we could just specify our auxiliary
function so
a u x i l i a r y
function and what we could say over here
is we would just set the same void m r
g s o r t and now the same input
parameters where we have
an array so we have this input array
we have basically the start value and
then we have the n value
okay these are basically the indexes and
we call this as the
auxiliary function or we also known as a
say helper function these are some of
the names
we could use so let's have a base case
to this
now yeah i don't know what a merge sort
is right now we just basically drew out
the thing over here so we have this
function and calls it another function
now the scenario here we have is
basically
a same array and somehow it's sorted in
sections so you have a first
part which is sorted and the second part
is sorted
and what we our job here is don't think
of this
as just two arrays this is one single
array and somehow
we have this first part sorted and we
have the second part sorted and our job
is to make this sorted in one whole and
how we can do this
is the process of merge so we're going
to use merge sword algorithm
to do this so what we can do is we have
to know
in advance how the first part is sorted
or the second part sorted and we have to
put a trust
we have to put faith in one process and
that famous process is called recursion
and now that's what we're going to be
applying so you're going to check
and the process is going to go like this
so we're going to have this first
element two
and we're gonna check this third out
this part over here so first first of
these two
sub arrays and i'm gonna say two and
three which one is greater i mean which
one is smaller
so basically two is smaller so a two is
going to be planted here
and then uh this is going to be
incremented so this sub in
array index is going to be incremented
so it's going to be plus 1 which is
going to be 7 now
and this part is going to remain the
same now 3 and 7 will be compared
and we could see that 3 is lower so 3 is
going to be placed in here
and now this is going to be incremented
to four so you could see
that four and seven will be compared and
we have four over here
so four is gonna be and now this is
going to be incremented to five
so five and seven and five is now gonna
be added so five is gonna be here
now it's going to be 15 and 7 so 7 is
going to be here so 7 is going to be
here
now 11 and uh 15 you can see 11 is
smaller so 11 is going to be in here
so um it's going to be incremented to
19. so we have 15 and 19 so now we have
15 over here so 15 is gonna be over here
and then we have uh this compared to uh
15 is going to be incremented to plus
plus so we have 18
and 19. so what what is it 18. so now
you can see over here we assumed
that this part is already full now now
what do we do well now what we're going
to do is basically
this this last part we're just going to
append to the end so that's our process
here what we're going to do is append
these
19 and 21 to the end how we're going to
do this and you can see by
this is just sorted in our ascending
order fashion and that's what we
required
and how do we do this and you would ask
me now
if it was sorted like this why not just
put like a pre-existing sorting
algorithm like merge
like something like insertion sort or
selection sort well that process is
going to take
longer and this process is fairly
shorter that's the crux of merge sword
and that's why it makes it faster it's
much more faster as compared to any of
the sorting aluminum
algorithms we've discussed so far so now
let's go back into our
code and now let's start typing along so
first of all let's have this merge sort
and inside of this we have an array we
have this in
s we have this in e we have a helper
function out in the condition we have a
base case
now we have this s greater than equal to
e this is some case that's not true
it could never be true in this case it
would just return so this is our base
case
and that after that you could say that
this is this is not going to be true
because
start is never going to be greater than
or equal to e
that means that it's just a logical
always you have a start which is less
than equal to e and i'm talking about
the indices
over here and not the value so you have
a start like for instance we have a
start here
and we have an end over here obviously
these are indexes and indices are start
from zero all the way to n
right indices start from n minus one it
never does
the other way around so that's just
illogical and now we're gonna have the
implementation area we're gonna find the
midpoint value
of that array so this is our function
here so
what we have to do here is basically
means just uh let me just
put these plots back okay so our process
here is
we have to find the midpoint value which
is right here so you can see over here
if i observe here that i have
um one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten ten elements and if i
if i go from here like the start value
with zero index and the
last value which is nine and if i divide
this by 2 i'm going to get a 4.5 right
and i'm going to get the integer
division of it so i'm just going to get
the four part
the decimal part is just going to be
excluded so we can have
four 0 1 2 3 4. this is our fourth index
so this is our fourth index right here
and what i'm gonna do here
is i'm gonna place that uh value so
basically this is our four index
and we're gonna we're gonna split this
here and this is now you could see that
this is our mid
m i would say this is our m and
and the stuff that is before is going to
be
the things so 0 1 2 3 is going to be 4
and then after this is
0 1 2 3 4. so this is 5 over here and
this is 4
and this is our midpoint now suppose if
we added something
like had an odd number then we'd have
even cases here but in this case we
don't have but this still
is our process this is how it's going to
be implemented go back here
and we have this mid and this is going
to be a simple
function what we're going to do is going
to be s plus e now this is going to be
the
um the start index and the last index
and we divided by 2.
just like we discussed and i know that's
pretty
uh really simple because this is n minus
1 i told you over here that that's the
last element
e is indicating the last element and
it's just going to divide it by two
which just gave a 4.5 it's gonna be
four because if it's because it's an
integer division
okay so now let's have that merge sort
calling use using recursion
that what i was talking about so it's
gonna start from a this is our starting
point
now careful here that it's gonna
it's this is the array the starting
point is s but the end point is now
m y because now we're gonna try to split
into two
subarrays with sorted processes so merge
sort we're gonna call again
and the second time we're gonna have a
array it's gonna start from
m and it's gonna go all the way to the
end
so it's gonna be not m but m
plus one because now we're gonna have
this process
additional though so over here we have
this portion we want sorted
and we want this portion sorted so we're
just casing we're just discussing right
now this portion not
this not this thing over here not this
right now we're just looking at the top
so so i hope you got the point over here
that we wanted to sort it in ascending
wise over here and ascending y is here
okay so back over here we have this m
plus one and now we call one more
function
and that function is basically the
combined function
and the combined function is gonna be
pretty much something like this
we have an a array we have the s which
is the start we have the
middle value which is m which is the
last value which is e
and this combine will be defined over
here somewhere so let's have this
combine defined
so now we're going to do is basically
we're going to say void combine
and if i have that specified here
i would say int a and then we have this
array right here
we have an in s starting value we have
an int
m which is the middle value forget that
right and then i got the last element
which is
end and what we could do here is that we
want
a temporary buffer and i'll tell you why
just hold on a moment
so let's just create a buffer over here
and what it's going to do is basically
going to get some value from the heap or
it's going to get some
um so it's going to be in
a it's going to be a array from the heap
that we're going to get
and basically this is going to be
representing the for the
total uh size
of the merged
array what we're talking about and
what we're going to do here is that
we're going to have a kz go to s
and we're going to say while so while is
over here
and we can say k less than equal to
e and what we do here is buffer
and we say buffer sub k is equal to
a sub k and we could say k
is equal to k plus 1.
now what do you mean by this now i'll
tell you what
what this means the thing is that we're
creating
a temporary buffer that we're allocating
from the heap
and then we're going to de-allocate it
using the delete keyword but before that
we're using it because we don't want to
reassign it
in that existing array so we want
it basically stored and then we want
something over here so i would just say
this portion here b
u f f e r
this is the buffer this portion and this
whole thing i'm talking about the whole
thing
so this is buffer and this is gonna be
our uh
output array so this is gonna be the
sorted array we're doing in two separate
things because
if we um sort it in just one single
array it's gonna cause
complexities much more complexities as
just copying the elements
um so suppose we have this array so
let's just ignore this part because it's
not sorted right now and we just created
a duplicate
array that had all the values so it
started from k and it went
so it said zero all the way to the value
last one so if i go back here
you could see that uh k started with a
starting value and it was less than
equal to n value
and it just said buffer sub k is equal
to buffer sub k so a sub k
whatever the values were it's going to
sort in the buffer so it just
initialized all of them and just k plus
one all the way to the end
so just copy them made a duplicate right
so now after that we could do is we're
gonna have something specified here
right after this so once it's copied we
have i is equal to
s now we're gonna have one thing over
here which is j
and we're gonna say m plus one and i'll
tell you why
we did this and we also have
which is k we said that as s
i is equal to s
go back here and we have this i
and it's going to be over here which is
the starting value
just give me another color over here
i'll just get a little darker
okay so i is over here which is right
here
and the second one what we have is this
mid
we know that okay so other one we have
is j
is equal to m plus one so if i go back
here we have this j
is this over here and we know that this
is end point right here
e so you could see that this i
has to go increment all the way to the m
this is its last element
and this j has to increment all the way
to the end of portion here so that's how
we're gonna
compare the values like two and three
which one is smaller two
planted here go increment two to plus
seven
and then we're gonna say seven and three
what is smaller three smaller
plant it here and then put the rest so
that's the process what i'm trying to
implement through code i have to map
this out so that's why i'm using this
diagram
that's what what we're doing so we're
gonna have into k 0
s while let's have this while loop and
this is how this
process is going to go i which is that
value what i told you
this over here i is less than equal to m
and
j is less than equal to e this some
process is going to go on so if i
less than equal to m and we have
j less than equal to e we want some
process going on
so if that buffer b u
f f e e r f f e r
e r i and then we have less than equal
to
b u f f e r sub j
if this process is done so if
a buffer sub i is less than equal to
buffer sub k
now what we're going to do is a sub k
that process what i was talking about
that if it's less or equal then just
copy it inside of that
k um then the array which is over here
we want to sort it out so
we're just going to copy here through
buffer so it's a b u f e r
sub i so in the case if it's less right
if it's less or equal and then we just
increment i is equal to i plus one just
what we did over there just what we did
over there
so if i if that's not the case it would
just have an else
and we're gonna put something in here so
let me just
put over here the case here is that a
sub k
a sub k is going to be over here and
it's going to equal the
buffer so it's going to be buffer and
then it's going to have
sub uh j over here so we're going to
have
this j in here which is a sub k because
if it's not the case it's going to be
less right so it meaning
if it's less but if it's greater than
the j is going to be there and then
obviously we're going to have
j being incremented instead of the i
being incremented
so we have that and we have k is equal
to k
plus one well let me just have that
there you go
and now we have the condition here so
this is this
case over here this is a while loop and
we have another while after this
condition now i'll tell you
the reason why behind this um so we have
this while loop and after this we have
two while loops additionally
i'll tell you the reason why we need
those two the thing is
that if we compare these two like
suppose we had this two
and we had this three we compared it
that two was less and then we
incremented it we're just doing plus
plus so we did
but the case when we came here this 19
and 21 how these come
this array just got full all of this was
full remember this portion
but then we just appended these last two
inside of this how do we do that
automatic process
that automatic process is going to be
it's going to be done through two while
loops we're going to be including and
that condition is like
if i is less than go to m or if j is
less than equal to e now this is the two
conditions
and look at this carefully so while
um we say i is less than equal to
m so if this condition is like
still there like it's true like it broke
out so
the process here is that these two would
never become false together it was
always going to be one
one of them and not the other right so
if that case like j is less than equal e
that came and then after that we still
have is less than equal to m
um what we could do here is that a sub k
and this is the same scenario what we
did with the example a sub k is equal to
we're going to say
buffer so that we got the thing from
buffer and we said that as
j and what we do is basically
um actually we're going to have that set
with i
because it's i over here and we're going
to set that with i
and then we we're going to do is i we're
going to increment i it's got i
plus 1 and we're going to increment the
k is equal to k
plus 1. and if the other case is there
like
while j less than equal to e
we're going to have a sub k is equal to
buffer
and we're going to have that as j
sub there you go and we have
um j is equal to j plus one
and we have k is equal to k plus one
it's just going to increment the k value
and you already know where k is starting
um
this is k right here so this portion is
k
and it's just gonna go one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten all
the way when it's done
so it just keep on incrementing you can
see that j is over here eyes over there
and that's the process going behind of
it and then
once we're done with it we don't want
this extra memory we just delete
it so we just delete our buffer and
using this delete syntax is basically
we're gonna
de-allocate it from the memory and
that's it
now let's just have this uh additional
function that we need is basically
i think so it's a print so oh i forgot
my main logic here
in main so this is main uh
maybe i left it up on the top
yep that's a common mistake okay so just
delete that portion here
and let's just have a display function
at the bottom here
so at the bottom value right here let's
have a display function so it's gonna be
called void
we're gonna have a display and
we're doing is basically having an array
just like the small
other ones so have the size n and we're
gonna have
something which is gonna be implementing
like we have temporary
and we're gonna have that associated
with a sub oh what am i doing
it's not actually that it's i is equal
to zero my bad
so we're going to have while
i is less than n and then we could say
console output the array value array sub
i
and put that comma here and then we have
it just keep on incrementing plus plus
and yeah console output here
there you go and now what we do is
basically
run the code here so get a random array
again
so let me just get this array which is
right here
copy here copy and just paste it here
and let's just change up the thing over
here which is insertion or sort we're
going to have
mrg mrg mrg sword merge sword
so let's go back to our g plus plus
compiler
g plus plus m r g s o r t dot cpp
hyphen o m r g r mrg
sort and
a compiled mrg s o r
t there you go vola
110 and then 102 whatever 293
and then all of that and sort it in
ascending order
so that was it with merge sort and this
is much much more faster as compared to
any of the sorting algorithms we've done
so far so even selection sort bubble
sort insertion sword even the
problem that we did in the beginning
because those were
of time complexity of n squared oven
squared of n squared over n squared but
this merged sort
is somehow faster because it's doing the
time complexity in o and log of n so o
and then we have n and then we have log
and then we have that and inside of it
and this is much
much more faster as compared to any of
the other sorting algorithms
now if you get like a a set of arrays
from a text file
that i could be doing in my other videos
so stay tuned for my next upcoming
videos
and my channel you're going to be seeing
that we're going to have text files and
we're going to be looking and comparing
how fast is this compared to other
sorting algorithms because
uh if we have these o event squared uh
sorting algorithms these are gonna take
much much more time as the
uh input value increases it's gonna
exponent exponentially grow
but as compared to merge sort it's just
gonna be fast as
lightning because it's in o and
o n log of n whatever complexity
so hope you enjoyed this video hope you
liked it and
please make sure to visit my channel
which is called coding cleverly
where i have so much content of c plus
and i've done data structures and
algorithms i have done object oriented
programming i've done
the basics beginner level procedural
programming and
my my goal is to complete data
structures and then after that
i advance to other project based videos
as well as new
languages and technologies so make sure
to subscribe to that channel
and yes thank you so much for watching i
really appreciate
the support so thank you so much and
thank you
free code camp for putting my video on
their channel
really appreciate it